like this video that I sent you there's
nothing to do with anything okay all
right fair but is probably one of the
weirdest most wildest videos I've ever
watched in my entire life wait hold on
lemmya y'all ever season is so
incredibly off the shit's you pass away
for a little while what the [ __ ] all
right hold on all right if you're on
audio you have to see video man you have
to see this describe it to you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
Oh scream so loud it just like goes to
like radio hookin and then he is every
McDonald's app from like everywhere
around the world and there's just the
Big Mac phone the lockscreen is the Big
Mac the background all the images on the
phone are big you know the commitment to
do this bit is crazy dude my must have
spent hours prepping his phone for this
bro and then the performance what is
even that what is that album the one
we're before tonight Leto shoes and oh
my god dude so alright this the it's a
lot like TV static was coming out of his
mouth
Jesus yeah so basically this dude is
trying to find his cool pair of shoes
that he wants to impress this girl but
it's very hard because he's got to go
through all his McDonald's content dude
I just got here
[Music]
bro you know this improv is next-level
dude he did that for a minute that is
crazy
those are a script that's this is what
means they are gonna look like in what
five years all of them what five years
five mohit fried tic TOCs
yeah five months bro yo speaking of
speaking of Big Mac porn I finally saw
my first zoom conference porn clip on
Twitter let's um let's do a ad break and
then let's do the zoom point because I'm
very excited for the zoom porn
you